- Des femmes et des enfants
à la recherche d'un peu de paix.
Une marche à contrecoeur qui
les éloigne de leur Ukraine,
d'une guerre qui s'étire.
Elle est juste là, à quelques
mètres, la frontière entre
la guerre et la paix.
Ici, c'est tout un petit
village avec des services
pour les Ukrainiens.
Il y a de la nourriture chaude
gratuite qui les attend.
On peut aussi aller s'installer au chaud
en attendant des transports
pour aller plus loin en Pologne.
Dans cette halte, on a pensé
aux plus fragiles; il y a un peu
de distractions pour les petits.
On trouve également des
services médicaux et le docteur
québécois Julien Auger,
venu prêter main-forte.
Dr JULIEN AUGER,
médecin de famille
- On voyait beaucoup de gens
vulnérables, des enfants
déshydratés, des personnes âgées
qui avaient par exemple des
maladies chroniques, qui
n'avaient plus accès à leurs
médicaments.
- Il y a aussi ces blessures
invisibles, parfois cachées
avec fierté.
- Je soignais une dame, je me
souviens plus pour quelle
raison, puis son conjoint m'a
demandé un peu en retrait :
aurais-tu quelque chose pour
l'anxiété? Puis il m'a fait,
mimé des combats armés,
ça veut dire qu'il était été témoin
de ça. Il voulait quelque chose
pour essayer de pouvoir
dormir.
- Épuisant, surtout les deux
derniers jours.
- Le Québécois repart
après deux semaines intenses,
satisfait d'avoir été
parmi les premiers
à porter un peu d'aide.
- La petite différence que je
pouvais faire, au moins, je
savais que je faisais ma part,
puis il y a beaucoup de gens ici
qui font chacun leur part, puis
je pense que ça fait la
différence, au moins pour ceux
qui ont réussi à traverser.
- C'est long, depuis Dijon.
On est parti hier à sept heures
du matin et on est arrivé à
trois heures du matin à
Varsovie.
- Ce Français a aussi mis
tout de côté pour aider. Il est
venu avec des amis récupérer
une dizaine d'Ukrainiens,
dont les parents de cette femme.
- Ça va. J'ai vu maman, elle a
pleuré beaucoup ce matin. Et par
rapport à ce qu'il avait vu et par
rapport à ce qu'il reste en
Ukraine, je sais pas s'il va
revenir et revoir notre maison
ou il restera rien.
- De rares retrouvailles
si près de l'Ukraine. La plupart
ont un long chemin devant eux.
Certains ne savent pas encore
où ils poseront finalement
leurs petites valises.
La nuit est tombée, mais
le voyage n'est pas terminé
pour ces Ukrainiens qui montent
dans l'autobus. Ils ont pour
4 heures de route avant de
joindre Varsovie depuis la
frontière, comme quoi il faut
être bien patient ces jours-ci.
Ici Yanik Dumont Baron, Radio-Canada
en Pologne, près de la frontière avec l'Ukraine.